welcome to the GQ Men of the Year
edition of Hollywood Squares today we
have Aziz Ansari rashida Jones Rob Lowe
Jerry Tim Jim o'heir whatever
Aubrey Plaza Greta Chris Pratt Adam
Scott and Amy Poehler and I will be your
host my name is Nicola Aziz Ansari what
is the plot of Fifty Shades of Grey okay
there's this college newspaper reporter
and there's like rich guy he's like oh I
wanna have sex with you but like when do
weird stuff with like eggs and and
leather and stuff and she's like wow
that's weird
and then she's like okay I've got him
into it and then they start doing that
and then they break up and she's like
just too weird I don't want to do stuff
with like strawberries and like turkey
and stuff so let's like take a break and
then she's like you know what it was
kind of fun and then the guys like oh
let's go like have sex inside a bumper
car he's like there's kids everywhere
he's like I like this and he's like no
and then he's like come on and she's
like okay and then they have sex again
that is over I'm very impressed that is
correct
Amy Poehler where did Newt Gingrich want
to establish an extraterrestrial colony
New Jersey most impressive that is
correct
Christopher Pratt complete this carly
rae jepsen verse hey i just met you and
this is crazy but hey i just met you and
this is crazy but i just moved into the
neighborhood and i'm a registered sex
offender this is something I have to
tell everybody
no no no Rob Lowe how are you doing you
look very handsome today I like to look
into your eyes a question what is the
name of the actor who plays Jerry on the
NBC hit sitcom parks and recreation mr.
Jim Garner I don't know either I thought
it was Tim Aubrey Plaza which Olympic
gold medalist admitted to in the pool
Justin Bieber wrong rashida Jones who is
rafalca rafalca is a character from Lord
of the Rings that I think got cut out of
the first book most amusing wrong
Retta why did Batman's nemesis Bane wear
a mask in the Dark Knight Rises
I don't [ __ ] know I didn't say it
give the lady a banana
Adam Scott if you get this one right
I'll eat my hat what reality star did
Kanye West begin dating in 2012 and why
I know this one it's Tom Colicchio
because he's an incredible chef bring me
my hat jime mmm
Jim o'heir Jim o'heir
what is a credit default swap credit
defaults yeah no it's a financial swap
agreement that the seller will
compensate the buyer in the event of a
loan default or you know some crazy
credit event and then the buyer at the
CVS will make a series of payments which
are the cbss fee or spread and weight to
the seller in exchange he would receive
a payoff if the loan were to default is
that right I'm afraid we're out of time
folks coming up I will exhibit an
example of Gangnam style
you